résultat de ces élections régionales et
départementales
allons plus loin continue place à notre
second débat autour du secteur aérien et
de l'écologie avec une question faut-il
diminuer la place de l'avion dans nos
modes de transport le sénat continue
d'examiner en ce moment là le projet de
loi climat et des bas aujourd'hui d'une
mesure prévue par ce texte la fermeture
des lignes aériennes intérieures quand
il existe une alternative en train en
moins de 2h30 avant d'en débattre avec
mes invités on va voir les explications
sur cette mesure a de jérôme rabin c'est
une mesure phare du projet de loi climat
supprimer les liaisons aériennes quand
une alternative entre un inférieur à
2h30 existe en prenant cette règle à la
lettre les liaisons paris nantes paris
bordeaux et paris lyon serait interdite
mais subtilités du texte si la liaison
sert majoritairement à prendre d'autres
vols en correspondance
elle peut subsister seule la liaison
bordeaux orly seraient donc concernées
une subtilité qui a permis à la droite
d'accepter la mesure ça nous concerne
car qu'une ligne qui est la ligne
bordeaux orly nous avons souhaité
réaffirmer qu'il fallait garder le hub
de roissy je dirais pour les
correspondances pour pour les bordelais
qui souhaite se rendent dans d'autres
capitales européennes au mondial et puis
nous avons souhaité surtout réaffirmer
l'attachement du sénat aux lignes
d'aménagement du territoire la mesure
n'aura donc pas un grand impact sur les
émissions de co2 les écologistes
voulaient eux supprimer toutes les
liaisons remplaça par des trajets de
train inférieur à 3h30 comme paris
marseille et juge l'article
insuffisant malgré une prise de
conscience fait en fait un article de
loi pour une ligne
ça n'est pas sérieux donc ça n'est que
du symbole alors le fait que le
rapporteur n'est pas supprimé le symbole
n'est pas supprimé l'article est pas
totalement inintéressant ça dit bien
quand même qu'il y a un coût
environnemental un coût et le écologique
du fait de prendre l'avion donc je note
mes bons 2h30 c'est un seul vol la
convention citoyenne avait dans ses
propositions demandé de supprimer toutes
les
on substitue à part le train en moins de
quatre heures une mesure excessive pour
le gouvernement pour les députés et a
fortiori pour les sénateurs qui ont donc
choisi de s'en tenir à une seule ligne
aérienne réellement supprimé pour
débattre de la fermeture de ces quelques
lignes aériennes intérieures j'accueille
ce soir sur ce plateau vincent
capo-canellas ce bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur centriste de la seine saint
denis ancien maire du bourget une ville
d'aviation et président du groupe
d'étude du sénat sur l'aviation civile
j'accueille également mathieu clip
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directeur des
affaires publiques du groupe adp qui
gère notamment les aéroports de paris et
vous êtes délégué général de l'ucr
l'union des centristes et écologistes un
mouvement de soutien au mouvement proche
des manuels macron j'accueille également
sur ce plateau ronan dantec sénateur
écologiste de loire-atlantique
bonsoir bonsoir et puis nous serons à
distance pour ce débat avec charlène
fleury porte parole du mouvement citoyen
alternatiba est en charge notamment des
questions d'aviation
on va commencer sur cette mesure un peu
phare de ce projet de loi climat la
fermeture de quelques lignes aériennes
ou peut-être d'une ligne d'une ligne
aérienne en fonction du texte du sénat
ronan dantec qu'elle est et si vous êtes
d'accord avec le principe de cette
mesure c'est remplacer l'avion par le
train quand il ya une durée de transport
quasiment équivalente alors qu'il faille
réduire effectivement la fréquentation
de l'avion pour aller vers le train ce
transfert modal
il faut le faire parce que effectivement
transport aérien et met beaucoup de gaz
à effet de serre mais l'enjeu c'est pas
tellement de fermer une ligne ou deux la
question fondamentale on en a débattu
toute l'après midi c'est que le
transport aérien soit aux vrais coups
donc taxation du kérosène
fin de la tva réduite tonnes co2
réellement intégré dans le prix est je
crois que la question fondamentale
aujourd'hui c'est est ce que le
transport aérien paye le vrai coût de
son impact carbone l'ensemble des coûts
ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui c'est un
transport extrêmement subventionnés avec
beaucoup d'exonérations fiscales pour en
parler de ce coût du carbone aérien
vincent capo-canellas ce qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette mesure de la
fermeture de quelques lignes aériennes
intérieures qui a été proposé par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
est reprise avec des nuances par le
gouvernement c'est une mesure utile
selon vous ce que nous savons c'est que
la croissance soit le climat elle
voulait deux choses et voulait d'abord
taxes et l'aérien fortement
financièrement un moment où le transport
et un va très mal on revoit avec le
niveau d'activité qui est très faible
et puis elle voulait aussi qu'il y ait
une mesure qui interdisent toute ligne
aérienne dès lors qu'on mettait moins de
quatre heures en train donc nous
vraiment s'arrêter sur deux heures et
demie ce qui nous semblait un moindre
mal dès lors qu'il ya une ligne qui est
concernée qui est bordeaux et auxerre
france a déjà abandonné à l'essai de
bordeaux il reste bordeaux charles de
gaulle mais sur bordeaux orly
malheureusement pu se dire pour ceux qui
habitent le secteur
cette ligne s'est arrêté voilà donc ont
estimé que c'était un moindre mal et
qu'il fallait pas réouvrir l'alternative
ne fallait pas arriver est ce que le
débat reviennent sur les quatre heures
qui était la pire des choses et nous
avons rien faire mais le rapporteur
philippe tabarot l'a très bien dit tout
à l'heure sur votre antenne à nous
devons réaffirmer que le transport
aérien était utile au désenclavement des
territoires et que c'était une des
richesses de la france que d'avoir une
industrie aéronautique inventive on a
été pionnier on en a besoin pour se
projeter sur le monde entier c'est un de
nos atouts compétitifs voilà
contrairement à ce qu'a dit mon collègue
moi je vous soutiendrai très facilement
que ce transport est extrêmement taxe et
il paye y compris sa propre
administration ce qui n'a pas
d'équivalent en france et en europe et
donc il ya beaucoup d'autres taxes on
aura abandonné une bascule à faire sur
des taxes carbone
mais ce secteur est beaucoup plus taxé
qu'ailleurs en europe ce qu'il souffre
d'un désavantage compétitif
voilà donc le sénat à une position
équilibrée en disant oui il faut aller
la tradition écologique l'aérien oui on
doit aller vers une aversion décarbonés
vers des avions électriques vers de
l'hydrogène il faut soutenir ce secteur
pour qu'ils fassent cette mutation là et
à échéance de 15 ans ça sera le cas et
on aura un secteur grandement décarbonée
on va en parler de cet avion propre mais
je voudrais évoquer l'impact écologique
de cette mesure de fermer des lignes
aériennes
charline fleury quand on regarde
finalement le bilan des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de ses vols intérieurs
en france en 2018 ses vols intérieurs il
représentait 1,6 pour cent de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
france
est ce que finalement c'est un vrai
impact écologique de fermer ses lignes
aériennes
alors il faut bien rappeler que déjà ses
chiffres qu'on évoque ne prennent pas en
compte en fait l'ailé vers l'extérieur
on est vraiment que sur les lois
l'intérieur donc quand vous parlez de 1
million 6% vous avez dit en fait ce
serait plutôt autour de 5% qu'il faut
considérer d'autre part qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'en fait il ya des événements
co2 à l'aviation qui sont non
négligeables et qui peuvent vous
permettre en fait deux morts m ont
multiplié par deux ou par trois le bilan
le real bilan en faites réchauffer de
l'avion est par ailleurs donc sur la
question des lignes intérieures en fait
effectivement la mesure là telle qu'elle
a été votée mais qu'elle est en train
d'être votée et bien elle est
complètement insignifiante puisque on
passe de tuning ou la viti à 30 alors
que la convention citoyenne pour le
climat demandait donc quatre heures en
train c'est à dire 30 lignes tranquille
qui aurait été elle était concerné donc
moi ce dont j'ai l'impression c'est en
fait progressivement le gouvernement
puis les députés à l'assemblée et le
sénat ont échoué vraiment à rehausser le
niveau d'ambition du texte et ont échoué
à simplement être à là
hauteur des enjeux parce qu'en fait il
faut dès maintenant réduire toutes nos
émissions et dans tous les secteurs et
il est hors de question en fait que le
secteur aérien soit un passager
clandestin de du climat en fait à partir
du moment où le secteur ayant dit non
non on va pas le faire ça ne peut pas
marcher et la convention citoyenne pour
le climat là dessus et est très claire
elle demande est en fait un ensemble de
mesures qui faisait système qui
marchaient ensemble dans un esprit de
justice sociale donc si on commence à
faire notre marché a en lui un certain
nombre de mesures ici ou là et en
particulier sur le secteur aérien qui
est très largement exonérés de sa
responsabilité climatique dans cette loi
eh bien ça ne va pas fonctionner et
d'autres secteurs vont dire eh bien oui
pourquoi pas moi et pourquoi pas moi
donc je veux bien entendre parler de
compétitivité de d'avions verts mais
pour l'instant jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
toutes ces technologies là n'existent
pas encore et d'ailleurs les ingénieurs
de l'aéronautique forme de nombreux
ingénieurs de l'aéronautique le dise ça
n'existe pas encore là l'avion
décarbonée ça sera peut être prêt en
2035 mais en 2030 rennes 35 il sera déjà
trop tard il faut réduire nos émissions
dès maintenant et moi en tant que chargé
de mobilisation et bien c'est ce que je
constate tous les jours dans les marges
climat du 28 mars et du 9 mai dans la
mobilisation de soutien ou lens horde
alerte qui était sur le tarmac de roissy
le 3 octobre dernier donc aujourd'hui
elle nous assure une mobilisation de
soutien
et bien je constate en fait une grande
déconnection entre la société civile je
voudrais jamais agir eux mathieu cuit
pas je vais faire réagir mathieu cap à
vos propos est-ce que cette mesure de
fermeture de quelques lignes aériennes
finalement c'est un symbole inefficients
dans cette colonne politique écologique
du gouvernement
non d'abord il faut peut-être rappeler à
cette fille qui nous regarde l'impact du
transport aérien sur le climat c'est 2 5
% des émissions mondiales donc on est
quand même sur un secteur non qui on est
sur un secteur qui en réalité
extrêmement pointé du doigt mais dont
l'impact est finalement relativement
faible par rapport à d'autres types
d'industries le promu premier point le
second point c'est sur cette mesure de
fermeture des lignes aériennes elle est
assez inefficace parce que en réalité ça
doit se penser à l'échelle européenne au
minimum sinon 500 capo-canellas le
disais à l'instant
vous êtes dans une logique
concurrentielle déloyale pour les
compagnies pour le pavillon français si
vous aussi vous regardez attentivement
le parcours d'un passager qui
partiraient aujourd'hui de bordeaux pour
aller une destination internationale
la logique voudrait qu'il passe par
paris pour ensuite aller vers sa
destination internationale aujourd'hui
vous supprimez un bordeaux orly ben
écoute et passera par francfort y
passera par zurich où il passera par
londres qui ont d'abord des coûts
évidemment et notamment de fiscalité
moins en moins important que qu'en
france et donc c'est une fois encore un
coup porté à l'industrie du transport
aérien aux compagnies aériennes et donc
par conséquent à l'emploi est compris
dans les territoires et donc là il ya eu
ni à une logique par ailleurs l'ensemble
du débat sur la sur la convention
citoyenne
c'est en tout cas médiatiquement
focalisée essentiellement sur le
transport aérien
alors même que l'industrie a quand même
fait et on va l'aborder un effort très
important de décarbonation ces dernières
années en tout cas de réforme est
aujourd'hui visent à l'innovation et
ronan dantec disais tout à l'heure que
le transport aérien n'est pas assez
taxés il ya tout ce débat sur la
taxation notamment du kérosène qui l'a
aussi doit se penser à l'échelle
européenne soyons clairs et qui doit
permettre justement d'investir dans la
recherche et le développement notamment
sur l'hydrogène sur les carburants
alternatifs qu'on sait maîtriser
aujourd'hui notre ami d'alternatiba
explique que c'est pas une technologie
qu'on connaît et carburants durables
aujourd'hui on fait voler des avions
avec une partie de carburants durables
air france l'a fait tout récemment sur
un vol pour montréal est donc en réalité
ces technologies on les maîtrise airbus
travaille sur l'hydrogène est donc le
jeu l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est le soutien
des autorités publiques des
parlementaires
à la décarbonation avec des mécanismes
justement de soutien et du financement
public remonté que je rebondis sur
l'escaut dit à mathieu clip il dit
finalement et bien l'avion ça ne
représente pas une grande partie des
émissions de gaz à effet serre donc
est-ce que c'est totalement faux je vais
vous donner deux chiffres par les
chiffres à un moment si on veut
stabiliser le climat
on va vers huit neuf dix milliards
d'habitants sur cette planète ça veut
dire que chaque habitant a au milieu du
21e siècle c'est entre une et deux
tonnes émises par habitant un paris nice
je parle pas d'un paris new york à un
paris nice alberto c'est une demi tonne
de co2
les chiffres de l'aviation
internationale même des organisations
internationales de l'aviation
10 alors on est en période de crise on
est d'accord mais si le transport repas
ce qui est probable c'est 3 milliards de
tonnes d'ici dix à vingt ans émises par
le transport et 3 milliards de tonnes
c'est les émissions directes
après il ya des émissions indirectes
totalement un documenté scientifiquement
aujourd'hui les cyrus et c'est un coef
il faut métier par deux ou trois
l'impact donc je me suis dit que par
deux ça fait 6 milliards de tonnes
aujourd'hui les émissions mondiales de
co2 dans les 40 milliards
on va essayer de les descendre d'ici 10
20 ans verra mais 20 milliards avec les
3 milliards annoncés par l'aviation dans
le même temps ça veut dire que ça va
être un tiers d'ici dix à vingt ans un
tiers des émissions mondiales de co2
donc c'est un enjeu majeur d'ores et
déjà de faire en sorte que tous ceux qui
ont une offre alternative à l'avion
prennent le train prennent le train et
ça c'est absolument centre moi je prends
le train pour aller à cologne je prends
le train pour les bruxelles je prends le
train pour les âmes certains on n'a
aucun enjeu d'avion sur toutes ses
lignes là simplement il faut organiser
ce transfert un modèle et puis on a
enfin sans être long un problème de
justice sociale vous allez en voiture
parce que vous êtes une famille modeste
à nice vous payer la contribution climat
énergie
vous y allez en avion parce que vous
êtes un peu plus risque vous ne payez
pas la contribution climat énergie ça on
ne peut pas continuer une réaction
rapide de mach occupée appelant sans
capot les nerfs et c'est quand même la
notion de coercition et et
d'interdictions leur haute borne haute
valeur ses yeux ça ici
re non très important en quantité si
elle fonctionne pas en réalité
d'abord le grand public aujourd'hui sur
strasbourg sur bordeaux il a fait le
report modal de lui même quand il est
dans une logique de faire bordeaux
centre paris centre on va pas se mentir
en revanche il ya la question de
l'attractivité du pays à la question de
l'emploi est la question finalement de
la place de la france et vous savez bien
que c'est important d'avoir un réseau
aérien fort vincent capo-canellas
souligné l'importance de la dscr
territoriale et du désenclavement des
territoires est allé vers l'interdiction
et la coercition n'est pas quelque chose
qui fonctionne et qui qui qui est
évidemment contre productif notamment
parce que sur les marchés émergents dans
le monde
il faut regarder ça dans une logique
globale en chine en inde les
préoccupations aujourd'hui sur ces
sujets environnementaux sauve pas tout à
fait les mêmes vincent capo-canellas
sans manquant même sur l'urgence
climatique et ce qu'il ne faut pas
prendre des mesures coercitives tout de
suite des mesures alternatives pour
diminuer un peu là et bien l'utilisation
l'avion crois que ce que nous visons
tous c'est la décarbonation de
l'ensemble des transports et aimer c'est
la société
j'étais autant qu'on puisse le faire
alors après renom dont dave m'en voudra
pas mais quand même ce secteur il a
baissé de 20% ses émissions en vingt ans
et il se fixe l'objectif de les baisser
de moitié en il les a pas baissé de
l'eid de les baisser de moitié à
l'horizon 2050
alors après on est aujourd'hui à 2% des
émissions aux nantais qui nous lie
demain ça fera beaucoup plus moi je sur
une logique quand même où je regarde
qu'eux il ya un système qui fonctionne
qui sont les biocarburants les
carburants alternatifs
on a un problème de production en france
et de filières à monter et ça marche
mathieu plane et on a fait voler des
avions est ce un grand % riendeau de
carburant il faut travailler cette
filière on a fait vous les avions à 100%
ok ça ça marche ensuite il a dû électri
sur les petits avions et ensuite on
verra sur l'hydrogène à le moment venu
mais ça me paraît une technologie qui
n'est pas encore mature le gouvernement
s'y fit sénologie ambitieux qui veut
dire en 2035 mais nos jeunes
fonctionnera t voilà je dire on va vers
une aviation décarbonés et c'est
l'objectif c'est sur ça que je veux
qu'on se concentre
après évidemment il faut trouver une
intermodalité il faut réduire tout ça
mais quand même
il ya ça représente 6% des kilomètres
parcourus en france l'avion dont on
focalise beaucoup sur l'avion mais il
n'ya pas que l'avion qui produit
malheureusement du co2 il faudrait
logique globale
ce secteur est un secteur de technologie
qui va de l'avant qui innove qui nomme
mondialement et donc il va régler cette
affaire là qui complexe il faut encore
un petit peu de temps mais on est dans
cette logique là et c'est ça qui va qui
veut lui doit primer pour nous c'est à
dire se fixer l'objectif n'avait sont
vraiment décarbonés s'en donner les
moyens
le paradoxe veut dire quand même c'est
que aujourd'hui d'aviation a investi
beaucoup pour y arriver ça réclame
beaucoup d'investissement et c'est un
travail de recherche colossal et c'est
le moment où on voudrait en plus à taxer
en même temps faut choisir les mules à
soutenir cette aviation pour qu'elle se
transforme plutôt que la mettre par
terre au pire moment à l'entretien où
elle traverse effectivement une crise
historique et on va parler d'économie
car dans ce débat au sénat
il ya une question qui est posée si on
ferme certaines lignes aériennes est ce
qu'on va déséquilibrer l'activité
économique des territoires
regardez ce qu'en pense le sénateur de
l'hérault henri cabanel c'était tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle du sénat
cette mesure aurait un impact important
sur notre activité de certains
territoires et sur les citoyens qui
pourraient voir leur talent de trajet
longe et sans oublier les difficultés de
la mise en oeuvre
quant à l'identification des vols
concernés les liaisons aériennes est un
vital pour les territoires enclavés les
industrie et pme dont la compétitivité
des pins charlène fleury est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ceux qui critiquent
ces fermetures de lignes aériennes
est ce qu'avec une telle mesure on va
contraindre la compétition mais quelle
compétitivité économique pardon de
certains territoires
écoutez je ne pense pas du tout en fait
quand on parle de quatre heures entre on
parle pas de territoire enclavé du tout
on parle pas de territoires qui sont qui
sont loin enfin je veux dire paris
marseille et 3h30 et c'était justement
pour inclure ce genre de lignes qui sont
green qui sont vraiment très fréquenté
et qui sont très polluantes que que en
fait les citoyens de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat avait proposé
ce quatre heures pour rappel un
paris-marseille en avion ces quarante
cinq fois plus d'émissions de co2 qu en
train donc c'est quand même absolument
non négligeable alors que on est sur des
temps qui sont à peu près similaires
porte à porte en tout cas pour aller
dans le centre ville de paris et de
marseille
on va mettre le même temps avec la
navette donc en fait ya un moment où il
faut un peu sérieux j'ai l'impression
voilà donc enfin suis tout à fait
d'accord avec monsieur dantec sur sur
les chiffres et sur sur la nécessité
d'employer d'autres mesures en fait pour
contraindre et réguler le trafic aérien
et je pense que il faut pas penser que
la technologie va nous sauver que tout
va être on valoir une solution miracle
dans dit maintenant il faut dès
maintenant réduire nos émissions
et ça j'ai l'impression que ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui a été en fait qu'ils
aient compris par la classe politique
tout simplement alors même que le
rapport le prochain rapport du giec qui
a chuté dernièrement un bien il ya la
dépêche afp il ya et bien et castro qui
est une montre qu'il faut absolument
prendre des mesures drastiques
immédiatement sinon on va droit à la
catastrophe
donc je pense qu'il faudra non un peu de
sérieux dans ce débat et il faut arrêter
de nous vendre comme ça la poudre de la
poudre aux yeux et des solutions
techniques miracle qui n'existe
malheureusement pas ronan dantec une
question sur votre territoire la loire
atlantique sea et bien on supprime
bientôt la navette aérienne entre nantes
et orly ce que sera un impact sur
l'activité économique
strictement aucun il n'y a pas un en
textant apercevant mais je crois qu'il
faut quand même le dire ça vient d'être
dit mais le rapport du giec qui vient de
fuiter dit si on n'agit pas massivement
dans les dix ans les effets sont
cataclysme et sur l'humanité cder c'est
d'effondrement de société tr ce qui
menace de transport aérien c'est que
intel déconstruction de la cohésion des
sociétés que en fait on ne pensera plus
à prendre l'avion
et moi je reste convaincu qu'une partie
du combat climatique ce jour sur
l'aérien
s'ils sont là et rien on est capable
effectivement de comprendre ce qu'on
veut faire c'est à dire tout ce qui est
gérable par le train et par d'autres
modes de transport
on le fait maintenant sans attente et
alors le côté encore une minute monsieur
le bourreau camp lejeune nous dit nous
reste dix ans pour agir c'est pas
possible
on le fait pour ce qu'il n'est pas
transformable si facilement on va pas
fait on va pas faire paris new york en
pédalo comme je l'entends des fois là il
faut une compensation forte et il le
transport aérien à partir de là sur la
partie qui ne peut pas être transféré
vers le rail peut être un des grands
contributeurs essais des discussions que
j'ai avec air france et avec puisque on
discute à moi je discute avec air france
et avec l'ensemble des compagnies le
transport aérien peut être un des grands
financeurs de la transition avec une
compensation mais pas une compensation à
4 euros comme le propose qu'ancien ça
veut dire 50 100 euros la tonne
comme les les suédois le font déjà sur
leur transport aérien et d'ailleurs il
ya une baisse significative de
l'utilisation du transport aérien pour
les liaisons domestiques
c'est ça et moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
trouve avec le transport aérien
un accord là dessus une compensation
extrêmement forte
et effectivement on fait en sorte
d'aller vers le train pour tout ce qui
est transférable et y compris on a
probablement un combat possible commun
qui est qu' il faut qu'à orly on est une
vraie gare tgv moi ça je le défends
depuis très longtemps
c'était même un des arguments entre
autres pour éviter un aéroport à notre
dame des landes qui serait aujourd'hui
totalement inutile et je m'adresse est
bien celui qui travaille notamment sur
la gestion de l'aéroport d'orly en ile
de france
est ce que si on supprime certaines
lignes bordeaux orly on entend lui en
lui en lice à peu et bien déséquilibré
l'activité de la zone à orly bordeaux
c'est 600 mille passagers par an donc ça
ça évidemment un impact économique
important pour des entreprises qui sont
installés dans le bordelais ont une gare
en forme d'autres activités économiques
pas tout le monde arrive de paris centre
et va à bordeaux centre il ya aussi
évidemment la question de l'ensemble des
métropoles france du sud francilien et
du bordelais mais votre question le
porter sur les petites lignes et l'idée
d'aller vers l'interdiction des petites
lignes et qui sont évidemment celles qui
vont toucher le plus durement le le
maillage économique je pense à clermont
ferrand par exemple où il ya évidemment
des grandes des grandes industries on
pense à 1 michelin la seml le père
exemple fermeture de ces lignes en
finlande
vous avez aujourd'hui si nerfs qui a
passé commande d'appareils électriques
de petits modèles qui sont parfaitement
adaptable sur ces petites lignes là est
justement qui sont finalement la
démonstration que la rupture
technologique elle existe déjà
on entendait l'intervenante
d'alternatiba qui nous expliquait
effectivement qu'on était à 20 ans
aujourd'hui l'aviation électriques elles
existent réellement
c'est des avions de 19 places qui vont
bien sûr ces petites lignes pour le
désenclavement territoriales donc en
réalité l'idée d'aller une fois encore
vers de l'interdiction ou de la
coercition est inutile puisque ces
ruptures technologiques on sait les
maîtriser sur le long-courrier ronan
dantec en parlait sur new york par
exemple
là on sait que sa technologie électrique
elle ne fonctionne pas en tout cas n'est
pas assez mature et donc il faut aller
vers et vincent capo-canellas l'évoquait
les questions des biocarburants et se
pose ensuite la question du financement
de la r&d de la recherche et d'un assist
sur ce désenclavement des territoriales
vincent capo-canellas les lignes
aériennes ont un rôle important et donc
sur certains territoires enclavés
surtout il ne faut pas toucher aux
lignes ariana en visite vous dire que
malheureusement avec le président on a
vu ce que c'était que la décroissance du
transport aérien et que des fermetures
temporaires de ligne alors ont été
perçues dans les territoires comme étant
une situation de relégation et une
grande difficulté quand une entreprise
est par exemple
dans le cantal je pense à certaines que
j'ai été amené à visiter avec une
mission du sénat d'ailleurs sur ce sujet
là elle vous dis moi j'ai des cadres à
l'étranger je gagne des marchés à
l'étranger
je construis des infrastructures si je
veux pas envoyer mes cadres rapidement
sur les hubs franciliens eh bien je
déménage parce que je ne sais pas
maintenir l'emploi ici voilà donc les
les habitants des territoires ils sont
enclavés savent que l'aérien est
complémentaire du train et qu'il faut le
concevoir
ah si ensuite on ajoute une chose c'est
que air france compense aujourd'hui
l'intégralité ses émissions co2 sur les
vols intérieurs et avec la loi qui est
encore en discussion ceux qui
l'écoutaient 30 millions d'euros va
l'écouter demeure 60 millions d'euros
bon il ya quand même des choses qui se
font sur la compensation il faut aller
plus loin ce n'est pas suffisant ah mais
tout ça est à construire est en tout cas
nous sommes la france des territoires au
sénat nous ne devons pas oublier que
certes il ya le train mais que parfois
le transport aérien est complémentaire
et le marché se régule quand bordeaux a
accueilli deux tgv
la france a perdu 50 % de sa clientèle
sur la ligne en quelques mois donc tout
ceci se met en place mais ça prend du
temps et je vous déclare unis aussi que
sur le ferroviaire bien sûr que le
ferroviaire et mai - co2 mais si vous
réintégrez quand même le coût
d'infrastructure de la ligne du bas là
c'est tout béton qui a été coulé le
bilan était un peu moins bon ça met du
temps on en est oui mais en fait
agen sert à masquer la réalité des
choses la réalité des choses c'est quoi
c'est qu'on choisit d'aller à marseille
en avion parce que c'est moins cher que
il ya beaucoup d'endroits où il n'y a
strictement aucune raison d'aller
prendre l'avion
moi quand je vais à cologne je prends le
tgv pour amsterdam pour bruxelles pour
genève
il y a des tgv simplement c'est plus
cher c'est plus cher et on nous agite
agen ou clermont ferrand pour masquer la
réalité du débat qu'il ya un dumping
social fiscal environnementale sur le
transport aérien
pour qu'ils gardent c'est passager sinon
tout le monde prendrait le train parce
que c'est la seule raison est que il
faut pas se tromper de débat donc qu'on
garde des lignes d'aménagement du
territoire pour la corse est sûr qu on
ira en avion qu'en garde ces lignes la
con qu'on pense réellement mais on en
est très très loin aujourd'hui et le
risque avec korcia c'est de faire ton
brilleaud prix d'acompte
encore une fois le transport aérien n'a
qu'une hantise c'est qu'il soit cher
c'est un secteur ultra libérale et les
low cost on comprend un participe et de
ça et qui ne veut pas de coup il ne veut
pas intégrer ses coûts et bien le jour
il y aura intégré ses coûts tu peux vous
dire qu'il aura fortement baissé en
fréquentation
charline fleury en même temps si on
augmente le coût du transport aérien et
bien on va frapper un secteur qui a été
durement touché par la crise donc c'est
pas le moment de taxer l'avion et et je
pense que ça c'est aussi un faux
problème en fait parce que la crise
sanitaire aurait pu permettre aurait dû
permettre de justement préparer ce
secteur aux crises à venir et notamment
à la crise climatique et de commencer à
réfléchir à une reconversion d'un
certain nombre de salariés il y avait il
ya des savoir-faire dans l'aéronautique
qui sont très très pertinent justement
pour la transition écologique pour le
train pour le ferroviaire pour les
éoliennes etc
et tout ça en fait c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut penser dès maintenant parce
que si on continue à vouloir relancer
coûte que coûte le transport aérien
et bien tout ce qu'on fait en fait c'est
qu'on utilise les salariés comme une
variable d'ajustement et que en fait on
va juste droit dans le mur plus vite et
à un moment donné et bien toutes ces
personnes vont se retrouver sur le
carreau
donc pour moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment pas opposé emplois et climat
mais il faut remettre en fait les
dirigeants du secteur devant leurs
responsabilités
à un moment donné vouloir coûte que
coûte pour suivre la croissance du
trafic aérien comme elle était en 2019
avant la crise co lead et bien c'est
tout à fait irresponsable de la part de
ce secteur
voilà match aux clés parce que ce serait
une bonne idée d'augmenter le coût du
carbone à rien de taxer le secteur est
la question c'est savoir pourquoi faire
déjà dans la période vous voyez l'état
du secteur aérien
notamment des compagnies aériennes 1 à
quelle échelle ce qu on le fait à
l'échelle européenne avait quand même
des compagnies extrêmement concurrentiel
qui sont dans le golfe en particulier et
qui pose évidemment problème de
compétitivité majeur au pavillon
européen dans son ensemble
le premier point est deuxième fois pour
quoi faire si c'est pour aller financer
de la recherche et du développement pour
aller financer la transition du secteur
et puis au fond pour offrir un avenir
positif et radieux à l'aviation
ça peut discuter si c'est finalement
être encore une fois dans une logique
punitive et pour ne rien dire logique
punitive
c'est un gars qui ne veulent rien dire l
accès qu'à une publicité ce qui va se
passer dans dix ans si le giec 10 effets
cataclysmiques sur l'humanité sur la
cohésion de nos sociétés et ckoi l'une
l'écologie punitive
la punition c'est des émissions de co2 a
saisi son habitation vincent
capo-canellas ça ne veut rien disent
lassés des éléments de langage vide de
sens pour qu'on arrête avec des aimants
langage qu'on discute sérieusement
vincent on discute sérieusement sur
certains sujets mais si on si on enfile
des perles des avec des éléments de
langage qu'ils veulent rien dire on
n'avance pas ce que veut dire d'abord
c'est que l'objectif n'est pas la
décroissance
l'objectif c'est de démettre moins de
co2 et de préserver l'environnement tout
en continuant à regarder cette liberté
se déplacer et en gardant quand même une
industrie qui emploie des centaines de
milliers de personnes
je rappelle qu'au delà des compagnies
aériennes notamment air france mais pas
seulement
il ya quand même airbus il ya vraiment
un savoir-faire mondial on a tu allais
sauna safran on a une réalité c'est que
la france est un des pays leaders
là-dessus et c'est un des rares secteurs
qui contribuent temps à la balance du
commerce extérieur et on en a peu là
dessus
donc il faut quand même pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain mathieu donc à
l'objectif c'est de faire que ce secteur
se transforme
moi c'est ça c'est ça que je vise
ensuite ce secteur n'est pas
subventionner le faire et très
subventionné le faire nos coûts de 50
milliards d'euros par an aux
contribuables et rauscher ils n'étaient
pas payées par les compagnies c'était
l'argent public qui paye et l'aéroport
mathieu cri pour finir
c'était et gérés par vinci et donc c'est
pas tout à fait des fonds publics ce que
je vais pas là c'est qu'on partie quand
nous avons aujourd'hui un secteur qui
doit changer
bien sûr et ça ne peut se faire que dans
le dialogue il était temps être acceptée
aussi parce que après la désespérance
maintien occupe pour conclure rapidement
rapidement le débat évidemment une fois
encore il faut savoir à quel niveau le
placer ce qu'il est au niveau national
et quel impact il a au niveau national
et ce qui l'est pas plutôt apporter au
niveau européen et ensuite il faut quand
même être dans une réflexion où on a
face à nous un marché américain un
marché chinois un marché indien en tout
cas des marchés émergents qui sont
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins pro enfin
comment dire respectueux de ses sujets
environnementaux et l'union européenne
à cette échelle a la possibilité d'être
leader en la matière merci beaucoup
monsieur d'avoir été à mes invités sur
ce plateau ce soir quand ce débat et
madame et merci beaucoup charlène fleury
c'est la fin de cette émission allant
plus loin vous rendez vous donne rendez
vous dimanche à 22h30 pour l'émission
spéciale soirée électorale pour les
élections régionales et départementales
une émission présentée par rebecca
fitoussi et brigitte boucher et puis
demain dans notre matinale bonjour chez
vous à 7h30 oriane mancini recevra louis
aliot le maire rassemblement national de
perpignan très bonne soirée sur public
sénat
[Musique]